50 à 70 % d'enseignants grévistes et 50
écoles fermées ce jeudi en indre et
loire et dans le loir et cher un jeudi
noir pour l'éducation nationale qui
étaient dans la rue à l'appel des
syndicats ils dénoncent des conditions
de travail devenues impossibles depuis
deux ans avec l'épidémie de kovy d'
hélène chapelet a suivi la manifestation
à tour
ils étaient 1200 manifestants selon la
police réunis ce jeudi matin dans les
rues du centre-ville tourangeau des
professeurs des écoles des parents
d'élèves ou des personnels de
l'animation périscolaire tous dénoncent
les changements de cap successifs du
gouvernement face à la pandémie et la
mise en place de protocole est
inefficace ou inadaptées
qu'on attend un petit peu de
considération et puis surtout un
protocole plus simple à mettre en oeuvre
et pour les directeurs d'école et pour
les enseignants et aussi surtout pour
les familles et pour nos élèves
qu'on arrête de les faire tester tous
les trois quatre matins voilà ça s'est
compliqué donc de la simplification pour
tous en fait
quand on a des enfants qui sont malades
nous aussi on doit appeler les parents
on a aussi des protocoles au niveau de
la désinfection
je sais pas mais on a plein d'autres
choses aussi c'est tellement c'est
tellement défunt plein de choses qu'on
doit à mettre en place tous les jours
qu'on doit re vérifier qu'on doit faire
attention c'est hyper compliqué après
les plus proches
c'est la question centrale c'est le
manque d'enseignants parce
qu'aujourd'hui on a des classes qui
ferment parce qu'on manque d'enseignants
mais pas forcément en raison du coc vide
donc il faut impérativement que ministre
recrutent massivement des enseignants on
a des dizaines d'enseignants qui sont
sur liste complémentaire du concours qui
attendent à être recrutés donc
aujourd'hui ce qu'on demande c'est qu'il
ya recrutement massif d'enseignants pour
qu'on puisse travailler dans des
conditions des conditions sécurisées et
des conditions acceptables
selon le syndicat snu dit est faux il
s'agirait du 50e protocoles sanitaires
imposées par le gouvernement
en 22 mois de quoi s'arracher les
cheveux du côté des enseignants mais
aussi des parents d'élèves tous évoquent
de nombreuses heures perdues pour les
apprentissages des élèves